talk with him and then maybe get that
into the here come on in
hey larry mary hey what's up george
steve
thanks for having me i yeah i think i'm
ready all right
here we go
generally the concept is a serial idea
one of the main ideas was to have
depending on whether it would be every
10 minutes or every 20 minutes
a sort of a cliffhanger situation that
we get our hero into
[Music]
and each cliffhanger is better than the
one before yeah that is the progression
we have to do the trouble with
cliffhangers is
you get somebody into something you sort
of have to get them
out in a plausible way a believable way
anyway
do you have a name for this person i do
for our leader
i hate this but go ahead indiana
smith it has to be unique it's a
character
very americana square he was born in
indiana
what does she call him indy that's what
i was thinking
or jones then people can call him jones
[Music]
that's an important concept of the movie
that'd be totally believable
it's a spaghetti western only it takes
place in the 30s or it's james bond and
it takes place in the 30s
except james bond tends to get a little
outrageous at times we're going to take
the unrealistic side of it off
and make it more like the clint eastwood
westerns james bond and the man with no
name were very good at what they did
they were very fast with a gun they were
they were slick they were professional
they were supermen like mufune yes like
mifune
he's a real professional he's really
good and that is the key to the whole
thing
that's something you don't see that much
anymore and one of the things that
really helped mifune in all those
kurosawa movies
is that he was always surrounded by
really inept characters really silly
buffoons
which made him so much more majestic
well they shouldn't be buffoons
the one thing we're going to do is make
a very good period piece
that is realistic and believable a 30s
movie and uh
even in the sam spade genre even in the
maltese falcon there were some pretty
goofy characters but they were all
pretty real
in their own bizarre way elijah cook
yeah elijah cook might not have been the
brightest person in the world
in a way he was the buffoon of the peace
but at the same time he was very
dangerous and he was fairy
did you see the good the bad and the
ugly yeah the eli walsh character is
a goofy character but at the same time
he's very dangerous and he's very funny
and he's
we can have that kind of thing
the main thing is for him to be a
superhero in the best sense of the word
which is
john wayne clint eastwood sean connery
tradition of a man who we can all look
up to and say
now there's somebody who really knows
his job he's really good at what he does
and he's a very
dangerous person or even the clark gable
thing we talked about
yeah the clark gable mold the fact that
he is slightly scruffy
now several aspects that we've discussed
before the image of him which is the
strongest is the treasure of sierra
madre outfit which is the khaki pants
he's got the leather jacket that sort of
felt hat
and the pistol and holster with a world
war one sort of flap over it
the other good thing we've added to him
which may be fun is a bullwhip
that's really his trademark that's
really what he's good at he has a pistol
and he's probably very good at that but
at the same time
he happens to be very good with a
bullwhip it's really more of a hobby
than anything
else uh maybe he came from montana
someplace and he
there are freaks who love bull whips
sure they just do it all the time
you can swing over things you can uh
there's so many things you can do with
it
i thought he carried it rolled up it's
like a samurai sword he carries it back
there and you don't even notice it
maybe even this has to do with the other
part of this character but i was
thinking of kung fu
karate but i don't want to load him up
too much
it seems like it would be nice if one
stripped of his bullwhip
left him weak if we had to worry
just a little worried about him being
too
yeah that was what i thought that's why
i was sort of iffy about throwing it in
if we don't make him vulnerable what's
he afraid of he's got to be afraid of
something
if we don't make him vulnerable he's got
no problems we'll shout that idea for
now
assume there's an archaeologist who
spent years studying this
he might have some kind of awe and
respect for
virgin tombs oh does it bother him to
go in and maybe he thinks that most
archaeologists are just full of [ __ ] and
that somebody's gonna rip this stuff off
anyway
better that he rips it off and gets it
to a museum where people can study it
and rip it off right he knows not to go
in there like a bull in a china shop and
destroy half the stuff that's valuable
i like that the doctor with a bullwhip
yeah it's sort of an odd juxtaposition
peter falk is one way of looking at him
a humphrey bogart character
the fact that he's sort of scruffy and
not the right image but
peter's describing yeah we'll figure a
way of laying that out in his
personality so it's easily identifiable
remember the movie soldier of fortune
with clark gable there was a
good deal of rhett butler in that
character the devil may care kind of guy
who can handle situations yeah he just
can't settle down
it's a nice contrast it's like the james
bond thing
instead of being a martini drinking
cultural kind of sophisticate
he's the sort of intellectual college
professor james bond
he's a super agent clark kent yeah it's
that thing which is fun
it's the same idea only twist it around
a little bit
the film starts in the jungle south
america someplace
we get one of these great scenes with
the pack animals going up the mist
covered hills
very exotic mist filled jungles and
mountains we actually talked about it a
little different from this but you can
correct me if i've gone off what we
talked about the last time where he goes
in the cave
this is where he goes into the cave we
had it where there's a couple native
bears whatever
and sort of a couple of mexican well not
mexican let's put it they're like mayan
yeah they're they're the third world
local sleazo's
four men the guys he hired they speak
english he's a partner with these other
two guys
well they're not very trustworthy eli
wallish types
it's all sort of misty and primeval king
kongish
the pressure builds and one of the
natives cracks throws down his thing and
scurries off
also in the process of this you
understand that the two guys are
plotting against the other guy
one of the guys tries to kill him and
take the map shoot him in the back
that's when you first see him with the
bullwhip that's where the plot comes
alive
so he and the other one guy go into the
temple you know the guy's going to shoot
him in the back
eventually as they get into the temple
you get into all these things
like there's this giant spider in there
they're walking
and our hero goes into a shadow when he
comes out of the shadow
there's two tarantulas on him he doesn't
notice him right away he goes into
another shadow
and he comes out with four tarantulas on
him
it's getting crazy with the tarantulas
and it's all very spooky
we get to a point in the tomb and we do
this thing where there's like this
light shaft coming down from inside the
temple a little
beam you see him look at it we had him
go through the wall
uh actually we had it happen first what
happened we had it first where he sees
the light and he tosses a thing in it a
stick
and these giant spikes come out and go
when spikes come out and
go like that there should be remains
skeletal remains
skewered on some of them of victims that
have been there before
it's kind of like one of those rides at
disneyland why are we letting the second
sliso get away
why can't we sacrifice him to the temple
we can
i just did it as building the pressure
but we can keep him in we'll follow it
through and then we'll see where you
want to dispose of him
if the hero tells him to stick with him
and the guy in his panic makes that
fatal one step sideways
you can build the terror and there's
seismic rumblings all the time there's
stalagmites things going drip drip drip
it's gonna be a sound experience going
through that cave and there's nothing
more terrifying than skeletons yeah that
kind of stuff
you don't know what's going to happen
this is the first scene in the movie
this scene should get at least four
major screams the audience won't trust
anyone after that
they won't trust the film oh there's
also the thing you can do which is your
famous
jaws which is not only skeletons but we
can have skeletons that
aren't that old they just have drawn
skin all over them
that are lurking in the shadows anyway
he goes through a series of really
spooky scary things what we're doing
here really is designing a ride at
disneyland yes
they get into the main throne room
there's a temple figure idol whatever
he moves in and he studies it it's
almost like a karate or a tai chi
exercise
he studies the whole thing he knows it's
a trap all these sort of silent things
that are in there
oh i know what one of those things was
poison sticks that were put into the
walls
you spring something it shoots out
they're all over the place
he sees one he does one he looks around
and the whole room
is a sort of honeycomb that's a great
idea yeah there's just holes everywhere
each one is attached to uh uh they don't
have to be big spears they're like
arrows or like little projectiles
yeah yeah little darts obviously there's
some sort of weighted trap thing there
too
take one step and turn and then all of a
sudden you hear the
he hears it and i have one of two
choices
one he just runs like hell to try and
get out of the room before whatever it
is
or but then i've got all these things
i want it to be action
you know what it could be i have a great
idea when he goes into the cave it's
not straight the whole thing is on an
incline on the way in
he hears this grabs the thing comes to a
corridor
and there's a 65-foot boulder that's
form-fitted
to only roll down the corridor coming
straight at him
and it's a race he gets to outrun the
boulder it then comes to a rest blocks
the entrance of the cave
nobody will ever come in again this
boulder is the size of a house
it matches the partner right the guy
can't run fast enough it's all that kind
of thing
stone ancient gyrations of things that
are so fun
it's really sort of land of the pharaoh
stuff giant crazy traps that were sent
so long ago to keep people from getting
in there dr jones now
you must understand that this is all
strictly confidential
the next scene is in washington this is
where we get the big assignment scene
with the blackboard
this is where they explain about the ark
i think also
you've been describing this to people as
a science fiction film which is good i
have not it's in rolling stone
[Music]
anyway the idea is that you explain the
arc in the power it held and the fact
that they have been searching what they
want him to do is get it before the
nazis do
the thing of it is that in the end they
convince him to do it because they say
this european version of himself is the
one who found it
he's the corrupt version of our guy he's
like moriarty
when that name comes up his ears perk
and a whole change comes over him
you realize that this thing goes way
back with this grudge it's moriarty and
sherlock holmes
he could be french or italian
no italians are too crazy
indiana jones
where does he meet the girl then nepal
yeah she is running this american hostel
in bar
rick's place in the middle of nepal in
some little village
she's a rough and tumble girl he's
sitting there with the girl
cut to her saying long time no see yeah
i guess it has been a long time
or do you cut to him walking into the
bar and he sort of walks up and sits
down and she comes up and says
i don't want to throw away their first
sight of each other i would very much
like if
she didn't see him at first but he
witnessed her dealing with a bunch of
rowdies he's on the other side and
watches her in action
he gets a lot of respect for her she's
really grown up
then he deals with her i like the idea
of cutting to her and seeing her in
action
tough her feeling when he walks in is
here is a guy she loved
he left her all of a sudden out of the
blue he shows up
in the middle of nepal her first
reaction would be
my god what are you doing here or it
could be total stolen
i like the idea that she greets him with
disdain when he first walks in
she says you're too late he says he's
been traveling around
i wonder if her first reaction isn't to
hit him
something unusual not just a slap first
sight register
who it is still with that right cross i
taught you
hey juni long time no see wham and she
says
get out when he asks her for it she
could be all pissed off about that stuff
because that's what got her there
he says he wanted to buy it she says no
he leaves and she reveals that she's got
it
then the nazis burst in and he protects
her he kills a couple nazis
she says what was that all about he
tells her they're after her pendant
this could be a big fight i like the
idea that he's somewhere else
either upstairs or coming back in from
outside it would be nice if they left in
a huff
they fought or something he left rather
pissed
i don't think he would leave without the
pendant that's the only thing that
bothers me about that
so he goes upstairs and stays up
plotting how he's going to take it off
that makes him into a real rat no that's
all right he never does it
what he does is just the opposite save
her life no matter how you do it the
fact that he thought about it is the rat
part
rhett butler was a rat he wasn't a real
rat he proved himself by raising her
family
before that he was a gambler uh dealt
with cheap ladies there's a difference
between being a rat and somebody who's
having fun
he never hurt anybody i'm a little
confused about indiana at this point
i thought he'd do anything for the
pendant but he still has to have some
moral scruples
he has to be a person we can look up to
we're doing a role model for little kids
so we have to be careful
we need someone who's honest trusting
and true but at the same time he's
confronted with this difficult problem
we have a great thing when she won't
give it to him she doesn't like him
the germans come in and start punching
her around and asking where the pendant
is
and it's sitting right there what's it
made of uh it's stone i thought it was
metal it could be metal
it can't be wood because it's too old i
love the idea
of fire when it rolls across the floor
could it roll
into the fire you don't think it's gonna
burn up but he has to retrieve it
maybe at the same moment he uses the
fire as a weapon
i'd love it if he burns down her only
steak in the world which is the inn
that's a good idea i like the idea of
doing the old branding iron scene before
he burst in
i love branding iron stuff it's a red
hot poker when he comes in he
knocks the poker out of their hands the
poker goes into the curtains and
immediately starts the fire
they fight when it's all over they end
up with the pendant
and a pile of rubble wouldn't the
germans pull guns and start shooting
yeah but he comes in and uses his whip
he also maybe has a gun this nazi is
struggling with our hero
they're kind of rolling around on the
ground and one of these henchmen is
standing in the doorway
trying to get a clear shot because they
keep moving
two of the other germans who are
struggling with the girls say
shoot some boss the german who's rolling
around with our hero panics
pulls out his own gun and shoots the guy
with the tommy gun kills them both to
save himself
[Music]
how do you guys feel about subtitles i
don't like them i don't either i think
it is better if we don't understand what
they're saying
i like hearing english with a german
accent today is history
and you are part of it please
i like america you people have nothing
to bargain with
you'll never get the land back okay
let's say the arch villain is
french when he's speaking to this german
maybe
they could speak english maybe the arch
villain is smart enough to speak german
but
they're not smart enough to speak french
well what about the arab kid
he's just talking endlessly and you
never understand what it is but if he's
going to be the buffoon character
you're going to want to understand maybe
he slows down once in a while to say
something stupid
when he talks fast you just don't care
and we might be able to play on that
it's conceivable that he and his father
could speak english
because they work with english
archaeologists all the time yeah i'll
just write the entire movie in english
[Music]
now she i don't know what we do with her
how about if we have her kidnapped who
would kidnap her and for what reason
if he gets jumped on the street and they
take her it's obviously the nazis this
is where you can have a great street
fight
maybe he uses bull whip in the process
she gets captured
how does he react to that does he go on
to see his friend or does he go right
after her
yeah it seems pretty mundane that he
would go on to his friend after that
is there some way to really convince him
that she's died
that's fun but you have to do it really
well
and i don't know how it could be the
obsession trick
the car she's in goes off and disappears
then it goes off a cliff and burns
we and indy feel that she's dead when we
see the car burning at the bottom of a
cliff
that would work
then we have the scene with the old
friend it will be better because he
feels terrible
it might be interesting to zap it with
something some kind of
thing to hype that scene in terms of
action and suspense and terror
maybe somebody plants a bomb while
they're talking and they're absent by
the germans
somebody who was following him what if
the guy who's bringing the tray of food
is pouring powder in all the drinks and
off of the food and the soup
he's laced everything with poison for
both of them at one point our hero would
take the chicken
and start gesturing with it he's too
caught up to eat it
he's not paying attention and this cat
jumps up on the table and
nibbles on the food the cat freaks just
goes crazy
jumps up climbs the walls he says i'm
not gonna eat this
what if it's an animal we hate an animal
the audience can't stand
a monkey is a perfect thing maybe this
arab operative
is the one who has the monkey it's a
villain monkey
the arab can make him do things and he
sends him in there to steal the peace
the little monkey goes to the girl or to
the guy and makes friends
and tags along he's like a little spy it
has to happen real quick because it's
very short until the time we want to
kill him before we
kill this monkey i want to really make
him a villain
what if he's along when they're headed
out to the friends
the ambush takes place and as india is
fighting them off
the girl jumps into a basket to hide and
the monkey leads the arabs to the girl
that's how they get her that's good the
monkey should be dressed up as a little
arab
i like the idea of not only having a
turban but also a little backpack
could we get the monkey to do a heil
hitler that's up to you and the trainer
and the monkey
he goes about a quarter of a mile away
to dig up the real temple
at this point we either dissolve any
breaks through or we cut to the villains
this might be an interesting place to
start going to the villains we can tell
parallel stories
we cut back to the girl and the villains
come back we have a scene with the
villains torturing the girl a little bit
she's so tired of being tied up and
pushed around she becomes a real active
part of the story now what if she became
involved with the frenchman
for her own purposes she's a free spirit
a tough woman of the world
which would appeal to him she's been
deserted by her guy
the frenchman wants her even though
she's not receptive to it say he's the
claude reigns character
it makes sense that he's attracted to
barbara stanwick the german says it's
time to get rid of her
and the french guy says no there should
be a real
slimy german character he's the only
gestapo involved there every time you
see him
you know it's going to be the worst pain
death by torture
this guy looks like a ferret he's got
that slick
black hair his name is himmler or
something like that we can do a
threatening torture scene
we've had enough of this young girl now
you're really going to talk they are
really angry with the frenchman
about the fact that he didn't pick the
right temple we sort of get their point
of view
zephyr wants this right away i thought
we had figured out how they chose this
spot
we had figured out that they had just
read the textbook i like it better that
the only way you can find out is to have
that piece
what if it rolls across the floor and
into the fire
and one of those guys sees it goes over
grabs it
and screams back here he says they had a
copy of one
part but how did they get the other a
man had it burned into his hand
does it solve that for you i love it and
at the time it's just like a joke this
guy burning his hand you don't even
suspect that it would be any kind of a
plot point
then you cut to indy and they're still
digging away and they say we've got it
there's that moment there it is
this is where we get into the trouble
with the water if we're going to do that
we might as well figure it out here
you could explain it frenchman says you
know so much about this thing
i suppose that you uh know about the
defense system that
we discovered in our diggings down the
street yes
an offshoot of the nile on either side
would be these giant cisterns of water
that were being stored there from an
oasis
so the water comes up from the bottom
you like it to splash the fact that it
just sort of seeps up
a geyser of water um
i'm not seeing what you're talking about
what would it look like
if there were like two levels and he
goes into one level and there's this
giant artesian well
water pouring out of old broken
fountains
you're never gonna convince anybody that
there's water there in the desert
why can't they close him in the temple
and lock the door and
all of a sudden you hear strange animal
noises the germans had put some kind of
man-eating animal to get him like a
couple lions or tigers
and all he has is his bullwhip and maybe
some clever devices hidden under his
clothes
we'll do an animal fight he works his
way out this little shoot where the
animals came out
somehow he gets out that way i don't
know how you know what it's like to fly
in a tiger from south africa
it wouldn't have to be a neighborhood
tiger there aren't any tigers out there
well i'm not in love with the idea you
could have bats and stuff
make it slightly spooky people hate
snakes
possibly when it gets down there in the
first place it's like
hundreds of thousands of snakes yeah
when he when he first jumps down in the
hole it's a giant snake pit
knowing that when the torch goes out
it's the idea of being in a room in a
black room with a lot of snakes
that will be really scary yeah the way
to do it is like squirm
it has more worms than you can imagine
snakes are
ugly when they're all piled up with each
other i wonder what their reaction to
light is you can get a snake charmer or
something all you need is a lot of
snakes in a very small spot so it looks
like there are a lot of snakes
everywhere
you can also do a lot with sound and
close shots of snakes slithering on
hands what's real scary to me is when
the rock comes down to seal the temple
we shouldn't have any snakes in the
opening sequence just tarantulas
save the snakes for now it would be
funny if somewhere early in the movie he
somehow implied that he was not afraid
of snakes
later you realize that's one of his big
fears maybe it's better if you see early
maybe in the beginning that he's afraid
i hate snake shock it should be slightly
amusing that he hates snakes
and then he opens this up i can't go
down there why did there have to be
snakes
anything but snakes you can play for
comedy the one thing that could happen
is that he gets trapped with all these
snakes
down here after we go through the
villains dealing with the girl
andy finds the thing the germans appear
the girl
ought to be with them as the thing slams
shut you see her mixed emotions but
she's siding with the rival the other
thing they could do is throw the girl
down there with him
in the snake pit yeah that would be a
natural thing they don't need her
anymore
i've seen that in so many movies they
throw them in together to suffer their
fate it would be a great stunt
say it's like 20 feet down or further
they just throw her in
and the guy would have to catch her love
among the snakes what if
the frenchman made her wear strange
clothes i'd love to discover her in the
strangest outfit you've ever seen
because he wants her dressed up like
some sort of crazy princess she's
apologizing
i can't help it he made me put this on
something completely ridiculous for the
escape
[Music]
the one thing is to make the whole thing
plausible especially the ending
so you can assume the whole thing was
covered up is lost in nazi files
but this really happened maybe we could
figure out a way where he's going to
sabotage it
not only does the thing blow up but he
has to set some kind of a time bomb that
will blow the whole place up
the guns of navarone worked because it
was a mission movie they had to destroy
something rather than capture something
his assignment is to recover the ark
but if you see a submarine base you blow
it up
the problem i have is that we wind up
the way every bond movie has ended
he's on the island he has to get out
there with the girl and they do get out
they're on the water and the whole place
blows up i love that
every bond movie has made money too if
you follow classic dramatic plotting
that's what is going to happen
i think it would be better if we just
let the villains get scrunched and
that's how he gets away from them
i like the idea of the whole island
blowing up and finding a clever way for
them to survive whatever that is
what if the guy opens the ark you
visualize that it explodes and then the
top slams down again
it takes care of everyone and we see a
lot of this uh electrical stuff
zapping people and starting fires like
everywhere
that's possible i saw the opening of the
ark in the resulting chaos as the climax
of the movie
the quicker we get from that point to
fade out the better you let the effect
go for a little bit
then you cut outside and the arcs are
going around it makes them very godlike
if one of the bolts doesn't zap him if
we make the effect real it shouldn't
last long or that hurts it
cut to washington our guy is getting
congratulated they created up put it in
an army warehouse somewhere
that's how it ends very bureaucratic the
feeling is that the ark is the real
thing
that it really is a very powerful thing
supernatural it's sitting down in the
government warehouse
the bureaucracy is the big winner in the
film
headline hitler invades poland
without the ark
[Music]
[Applause]
and so i told him the story of indiana
jones and he said oh that's it let's do
it
we go back we'll hire a writer and we'll
get going on it and we spent three days
with the tape recorder going
and in those three days larry george and
i pretty much outlined
and sketched in the whole plot george
had things he wanted in the movie and
stephen had
kinds of scenes he wanted to shoot and
we were
creating a story that would support all
these
ideas
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay this is jack not george lucas
anymore if you want to see the
transcript in its entirety
there's a link in the description to
check it out yourself might i suggest
page 37
which has a pretty scandalous
conversation about how old marion should
be
if you liked what we did in this video
we performed another conversation from
the transcript
that became a scene in the second
indiana jones film you can watch that
conversation in a bonus video found
exclusively on nebula nebula is a
streaming service that supports
exclusive ad-free videos from youtube's
top education creators
i love nebula because it's a platform
made by creators for creators
and it helps me make videos without
having to worry as much about the pesky
youtube algorithm you can watch that
exclusive video on nebula right now with
a link in the description all thanks to
nebula's partnership with
curiositystream an award-winning
streaming service with thousands of
documentaries and non-fiction titles
i'm certain that steven spielberg a
world war ii fanatic would love their
documentary five submarines against the
nazis the story of the u.s submarines
that made the liberation of france
possible
if you sign up for curiosity stream with
the link in the description you get
access to curiosity stream and nebula
this partnership is honestly one of the
best deals in online streaming for less
than 15
a year you get access to an incredible
library of educational content while
also supporting your favorite online
creators which i hope includes me
clicking that link in the description is
a way of showing that you liked this
video and that you want to see more like
it
and as always along with nebula my
patreon supporters also got the bonus
episode a big thanks to them for helping
out the channel
thanks for watching